i keep hearing that china's a paper
tiger have you you've been studying this
a lot have you found stuff like this
and what i mean by that is that they're
putting on a big show of force but that
they're actually very weak and and
vulnerable right now as a government
so i mean you know it'd be cliche to say
act weak when you're strong and act
strong when you're weak and then their
strategy was hide your strength by your
time that was really sort of the
overarching vision of deng xiaoping and
then sort of build up and then you can
start acting very assertively and
aggressively
i think that i don't think that they're
50 feet
tall
and they might think that we're 50 feet
tall which should mean that we really
have to up our game because they're a
lot more serious than we are i mean when
we have our generals talking about
you know general miller talking about i
really want to understand white ridge
what kind of message
he means yeah i mean of course
what kind of message does that send to a
people that has no qualms about killing
its own citizens crushing hong kongers
threatening taiwan threatening
chinese nationals abroad in every single
country
they don't i don't think they perceive
us to be serious so that's dangerous
potentially that they have that
perception that we're not serious but i
think also it's r it's reality in a lot
of respects now are they a paper tiger
like if you're looking at how many you
know nuclear warheads do they have and
you go through all those conventional
weapons i don't think that ultimately
the conflict i think we're in the
conflict with china that that'd be the
first thing i'd say they've been in at
war in one way or another with us for
decades would be my probably since the
late 1800s since the opium wars well you
could go back and they would and that
and that would be a grievance you know
they have kind of their historical
narrative of the west putting them down
and controlling now they're going to
rise up and we're going to be you know
returned to our
being the center of the world the middle
kingdom
you know are there economic numbers real
i would put zero stock and you know we
grew at 35
last year yeah i wouldn't put any stock
in that whatsoever but where they
clearly have significant power
is in the realm of
influence over everyone else the fact
that you can bring an american to his
knees to kowtow over taiwan i think
tells you all you need to know do they
do that when it comes to america did
they do the reverse
and also they understand how foolish
we've been i mean the business community
just put out a letter recently i wrote
about this at newsweek talk saying to
the binder administration you really
need to go back to the table on more
negotiating with china because we need
to increase trade and economic
engagement with china and it starts and
you got to remove those tariffs as soon
as possible also we understand you know
there are all sorts of issues with
china's predatory economic practices but
we really need to get back to the table
and it and by the way it's america first
too it's good for the american workers
there's going to be an anti-inflationary
policy you'll watch you'll see
on what basis whatsoever would any
serious people say you know what i've
seen the way china's acted just over the
last 18 months let's definitely go and
engage more with them when that has been
the entire strategy it's been a bear hug
strategy it's let's invite the west in
they'll give us capital we'll steal
their technology they'll get nothing out
of us ultimately we'll have all of the
major industries dominated monopolized
so that during something like a pandemic
for example we can threaten to withhold
essential medicines from you so or
control 5g infrastructure the funny
thing about this is we have the the the
uh xinjiang province the uyghur muslims
and that i can't even make a joke about
them considering it when it comes to
these these trade deals like i'd like to
make a joke where there's like some
corporate executives being like
gentlemen
we've just got this report that they're
torturing they're forced there's forced
abortions these people are being you
know
ethnic cleansing is horrible we have to
consider our business practices with
this country i can't even make that joke
because when they're sitting in the
office some guy goes oh did you hear
they got a concentration camp huh does
it affect our bottom line not at all huh
praise the lord it's like all right
great what's our numbers this time
around oh anyway moving on they don't
care at all about that stuff collateral
damage so so you have to understand it's
outside of the fact that they're ripping
us off stealing our ip they're
threatening us in terms of the south the
south china sea they're threatening
taiwan one of our one of our allies and
our chips computer chips that we need
and they're also just morally repugnant
within their own country that's what i'm
wondering and we're just like america is
just like yeah but you know it's the cow
power you brought up the word cow a few
times it basically means i'm looking at
the definition here act excessively
absurd servant manner but it comes from
a chinese idea that you would go to the
emperor bow on your knees put your
forehead on the ground and beg
submission from the empire and the
emperor john santa and forward foreign
leaders would go to china and they would
bow and put to the emperor and like and
then you'd have the blessing of china
and they would send you money and they
would send you troops and they would
send you
architects and things to come work with
you
and is it still like that is there still
a chinese emperor i don't even know
right now is it a xi jinping well xi
jinping is is the emperor so they
dispelled with the empire now it's just
a communist party but he's still acting
as if the child he's the child of heaven
is this it's a it's it's a communist
party but with confucian
characteristics he's i mean look i don't
think that xi jinping is like this great
philosopher king dictator but but he's
sort of blended
propagandistically
the traditional chinese cultural ethosis
with communism and so he is the next
thing to mao i mean he's number two
after mao essentially there now of
course
like michael bloomberg talking about
like well he has domestic constituencies
too even though it's not a democracy i
mean
he has he has other members of the
communist party who would probably like
to have his seat but like i said he also
engaged in a purge soon after he entered
which he called an anti-corruption purge
which is basically taking out two to
three million members of the party uh
probably who he felt you know were a
threat to him i mean jailing not always
murdering them but you know that's just
another day
when king you know you got to kill the
king to be the king yeah who's the
what's the real power of china they put
mao or they put a what's his name xi
jinping in the front but i imagine it's
like an oligarchical dark state like a
quiet people behind the scenes that no
one knows who they are that are running
things he everyone is answerable to him
obviously like you know first of all
it's also worth noting their military
the pla is the chinese communist party
is military it's not china's military
it's a distinction worth making it's the
party's military arm and she has taken
substantial control over that military
in his time running the country
look it's very clear that the private
companies there's been a massive
regulate regulatory crackdown i mean
you've got to put all these things in
air quotes there but massive regulatory
crackdown jack ma you know was
essentially disappeared for months and
then re-emerged they scuttled the ipo
that his company was going to go through
his value went from 900 billion to 450
billion at least and it's probably still
dropping they're just selling off parts
of his companies to party members and
who else i don't know in july of 2021
u.s listed chinese companies lost 400
billion dollars in market value under
this regulatory crackdown you talk about
oligarchical powers i mean the people
running these companies who are all
party members obviously
if those are your oligarchs they're
being cut down to size in real time so
like their vulnerabilities i mean their
vulnerabilities which we'll never know
and do i trust our intelligence to see
them i don't know but that said yeah
look in a system like that with a
one-man dictator he obviously has to
answer to other people because they're
all at his throat all the time right not
his p not his citizens not the citizenry
and like who owns the party owns the
land so who owns the party
the goblin king whoever is that's what
they say that's what they make us think
but i don't think so i think mao was too
dangerous so they they make sure that
it's like a puppet now i i am not
convinced even our intelligence agencies
are uh genuinely con concerned with
preserving and protecting this nation i
think when you look at afghanistan and
and and the afghan papers what you
really have is
a disaster where everyone's just like i
don't want to get in trouble how much
can i extract from the system before it
all falls on my head
i think that of like every institution
i'm looking at and unfortunately
it's it's almost like with trump there
was this
kind of sporadic
bombastic
attempt at some kind of cobbling
together a return to
i guess some kind of nationalism like
we're gonna have borders we're gonna
have uh we're gonna put more controls on
immigration we're gonna have the
industries come back we're gonna try and
help the american people get jobs and
better their lives and that was a threat
to those who are trying to extract the
last little bit from the system so they
also collectively screen it's it's it's
um what's the right word for it
basically
the confidence in this country has been
lost for a long time to the point where
even our elites have no confidence in it
and they're selling out to china among
other among other sellouts you saw it
perfectly personified in the
conversation between the secretary of
state lincoln
and the national security adviser and
they're meeting with their chinese
counterparts in anchorage and by the way
what did china do to deserve to have
that high level meeting in the first
place if you're really serious about
them and you ascribe
primary culpability in the coronavirus
pandemic at the very least spreading
worldwide well of course they protected
themselves why would you ever meet with
them over anything i mean they should be
viewed as they're the most culpable
country in this and trump said you know
10 trillion dollars that's probably an
underestimation of what they should pay
in terms of recompense but that meeting
the chinese communist party dignitaries
basically said oh you're going to attack
us over human rights well look at you
you're a systemically racist country and
your history is awful etc and and
blinking and and uh sullivan the
national security advisor sort of like
well we accept your premise but
you have no moral comp you have no
confidence you have no vision basically
you're saying yeah we agree our
adversary is propaganda that the left
has put out about america for decades is
true they've drank the kool-aid right so
who's going to defend the country if you
say that at core it is a rotten
deplorable irredeemable country when
when you have a substantial amount of
people in this country saying that it's
a self-fulfill it is a self-fulfilling
prophecy and when you have this critical
race applied principles now manifesting
in our schools manifesting in our media
the rot has got to the foundation and
how long can the building stand
racial marxism that that which is you
know it's really just a rhetorical game
critical race theory in a lot of ways
it's it's like putting a a just and
virtuous veneer on your regressive
ideology of saying well we're fighting
for the good people and you're the bad
people etc but i i totally agree it's
the rod and the corruption is incredibly
deep on the other hand maybe more people
are awake to the fact that this is a
game that's being played than ever
before it's never been exposed i think
in such crystal clear fashion how
corrupted all the institutions are that
the blindfold has been removed i think
for a lot of people but the question is
how many people and how far gone are we
i am
i'm optimistic and pessimistic in a
certain way i think that when it comes
to the rise of china
you're familiar with the city's trap
we've we discussed quite a bit on the
show like so i think this is real fear
among elites that war is inevitable and
so if they hobble america it will
prevent that war from happening so it's
take the the crowbar to the knee to
america and then we avoid the war
because america can't stand up against
china so i'm pessimistic in that sense
i'm optimistic in the sense that i think
i'm starting to feel more and more like
what power cancel culture and all these
things had has been
weakened to a certain degree seeing
these parents start rising up one parent
actually punched a teacher like beat him
pretty bad that's an awful story man but
you see the parents are getting so fed
up with what's happening in these
schools they're snapping and we had
bannon on the show and he said come
august 15th when these parents figure
out what they're doing to their kids
they're going to go nuts seeing these
parents you know come up i'm kind of
like
aside from the i don't like the violence
but the parents going out and protesting
and saying no to these schools the the
the push for homeschooling or for pods
school pods where like local like the
kids in the neighborhood all go with one
tutor or whatever get taught
that's optimistic because maybe maybe we
get hobbled and maybe china does make a
big move and becomes the the the economy
of the world the super economy uh in
2028 or whatever there's real risks that
we're going to lose out if china falls
to to mainland china if taiwan falls to
china
and uh what that means for the united
states in terms of our resources our
access but i do think
there's always a light there's always
you know an open window and a doors shut
that's we're gonna start seeing people
start waking up to this the hard times
will create strong men and then there
there will be some kind of resurgence
that'd be if taiwan were to fall to
china that would actually be if china
were to fall to the ccp because taiwan
is china exactly the republic of china's
china the ccp's co-opted and west taiwan
is you know being has been taken over by
communists so that's true yeah so if the
republic of china can take back west
taiwan it was funny i i posted that meme
ever see it west taiwan and all of
mainland china says west island and boy
do people get mad
they don't like that one all the chinese
bots
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast if you want to
see the full show come back to this
channel youtube.com tim cast irl monday
through friday at 8pm where you can
leave comments and super chat and we
actually will read your comments on the
show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else go to timcast.com
become a member and we even have full
bonus episodes thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time
you